I have been clear that the price of
Justice cannot be the continued
suffering of all Palestinian civilians
even Wars have rules all innocent life
is equal in worth Israel and Palestinian
I urge the government of Israel to
exercise maximum restraint this has to
stop who the hell does he think he is
that he can tell Another Western
democracy how they should defend their
men women and children the the issue
with this is really the fact that he is
putting the responsibility on Israel
it's pathetic and I think you need to
ask yourself as a leader of a country
what would you do what would you do like
really you you would hold restraint I
want to read BB's response to uh Justin
Trudeau it is not Israel that is
deliberately targeting civilians but
Hamas that beheaded burned and massacred
civilians in the worst Horrors
perpetrated on Jews since the Holocaust